hey guys welcome back to brand-new video  we're back I'm foreigner and today we're  just gonna show off a really quick video  of the new season 7 executions that were  just released today this morning so I've  basically covered every single one for  every single character so let me know in  the comments below which one you think  is your favorite I love to know your  thoughts and with that like the V if you  do enjoy subscribe but for new I cover  the informational side of fauna that  being balanced changes new executions  new hero updates new leaks all the news  and information about the game and  what's coming in the future and with  that hope you enjoyed the video  [Music]  [Music]